good morning this is tim ferriss i'm
going to show you in three minutes
because I dislike making breakfast as
much the next person how to create a low
carb high protein breakfast that will
provide high nutrient density and help
it lose weight and there are only a few
things involved there is container of
egg whites this is a biology but you can
use egg beaters or any brand you have
organic flaxseed oil
this is spectrum this is an optional
ingredient but any brandy will do we
have in this case Southwest salsa mild
which includes black beans corn and
other things it has a net of two carbs
two grams of carbs per tablespoon then
we have just a bit of lemon juice and
the last ingredient is
chopped spinach so this is what we do
the first is just a small container and
you can you really use any Tupperware I
like to use smaller containers this is
probably about 12 to 13 ounces and all
more or less fill this up with spinach
because particularly once it's cooked
this will all go down and flatten out
that's the first and stick the top on
leaving a crack on one side pretty
self-explanatory and then on its
container we're just going to put in
about two to three eggs really I don't
put in too much about that much and
adding in the salt in the beginning will
allow you to use a lot less and I'll
press up put in ground black pepper this
is in some research been shown to
increase insulin sensitivity which is a
good thing and there we have it so the
top on this stick these in a microwave
for high on total of 10 minutes and
check on the eggs since I've used this
microbe before check out the eggs in
about one minute so I dislike using the
frying pan because the
it's not that I dislike cooking but I
dislike the cleanup therefore I don't
cook and I've tried every other option
you have cooking then you have also
going out to eat breakfast which for me
is a pain in the ass because you end up
waiting in line and consumes 20-30
minutes
so we have this here and if you're
killin time I tend to have one to two
busses wine in evenings so I can take a
swig
a little bit of wine a little bit of
resveratrol for those of you interesting
life extension and caloric restriction
robbed our vineyards for my favorites
so I'll have two glasses maybe a half a
glass or a corridor with that sip little
check on bags still in time and what
you'll find is that
this here with very little sugar or salt
added will be used to create almost a
wave of so than gentle with the egg
whites because egg whites are disgusting
by themselves at least they're very
bland I find them very unappealing so we
need to add something to it and this is
the best solution that I've found the
flaxseed oil is going to be added to the
spinach as will the lemon flaxseed oil
by itself will make you vomit on your
shoes you have a couple of options you
can either leave it out number two is
you can put about 1 tablespoon 120
calories onto the spinach don't use too
much because it has a very strong flavor
or you can just take it separately with
a spoon have 1 tablespoon pinch your
nose so that you can't taste it as
clearly and that will deliver a pretty
healthy dose of omega-3 fatty acids and
really fill out the macro nutrient
profile of since our meals so
you have everything ready to go
put just a couple of squirts of lemon a
small - very small - of omega-3 for a
flaxseed oil and then we're going to
take fork and whip up the eggs a little
bit and I'll show you what this looks
like and I will usually use right out of
the containers I recognize not everyone
wants to do that so so mix up the
spinach and if I were talking so much
and putting it on a plate and explaining
Expo cating this would be a lot faster
all right guys before the salsa again
just eyeballing it I'll take 2 2 or 3
spoons and just mix it right on top of
the eggs themselves and why not my
breakfast is done you can see it right
there
and if you're feeling particularly
ambitious you can take a container of
lentils open that up either put it in a
separate container or put it on one side
with the spinach and you'll have a
higher caloric density if that's what
you're looking for this is probably with
the flaxseed oil included somewhere
between two and three hundred calories I
am NOT a big proponent of a huge
breakfast so I'll start small and I'll
have another meal in two hours or so
which will be my main meal after workout
so there you have it the roughly three
minute breakfast very little cleanup
involved enjoy loosen fat Vincent muscle
be good